- So you're telling your
ultimate ambition is to go to
Mars, not the
$440 million, right?
- [Jonathan] But I want
money to be able to pay--
- Got it.
- [Jonathan] three
times as much needed.
- So you're
hustling to go to Mars.
The way Gary
hustles to buy the Jets,
he's hustlin' to go to Mars.
- I like his better.
No, I'm super happy.
Jonathan, I think you
should literally document
your journey to Mars, bro.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Dust Air" by The Muse Maker)
- [Gary] I don't want
people imposing old Vayner.
I don't want
people you know saying
now the grown-ups are here.
I don't want people saying that
new person created this dynamic.
People are confused.
People just don't know who I am.
And so I need to
unconfuse, in a real way,
and I need to start with the
people that I think get it.
Or as close to it potentially as
I think can happen and then chip
away at what is the last
piece or the seven pieces
or the nine pieces?
Like what is it? You know?
On an individual basis.
But we're just not as good as
we can be by any stretch of the
imagination compared to
what's in here and here.
And I'm just gonna do it now.
And that's gonna hurt.
And it's gonna be awesome.
You know what I mean?
That's it.
You know, working out
sucks when you're doin' it.
It's awesome.
You know what I mean?
Then you get to walk up a
fucking wall in one second.
There's just so much to do
and one of the great ways is
addition by subtraction.
And one of the best
ways is meritocracy.
And one of the best ways is
comfort and communication.
These things are tried and true.
I know how to do them all.
And I'm just gonna do it
better, I guess, you know?
I'm gonna do it better.
And that's that.
Like what I'm basically
asking for is what I do. Right?
Like everybody literally
walks in here starting at 100.
And then, through political
behavior they start losing or
if they're just not
good at their craft,
I mean it's important.
It is important.
We've had that in our ecosystem
but this is a game of the truth
of the truth versus
the perceived truth.
That's what this
conversation's about.
I mean it and I mean
it across the board.
I mean it.
Because it's just binary.
Either you just blindly believe
that all the intent's right and
this is a moment in time and
if it's too long of a moment in
time that your move will be
I'll go talk to Gary and then
I'll get the 411 and then
I'll go back out or you don't.
That's it.
Those are models.
That's it, either
it's all good, always and
forever is the greatest.
Oh fuck, I don't
feel that now for me,
for Harry that's
three straight weeks.
You know, for
James it's four months.
Oh, oh, I feel it.
Go in, get an update,
get your fuckin' answer,
clean, simple,
the answer, the answers,
the series of answers,
kick back out.
That's what I want.
And so when you're producing
content because of the search
capabilities because of
the utilitarian nature of the
content, people will post
about food on Instagram and on
Pinterest, there's much more
to do with it on Pinterest.
It has the intent for it to be
deeper and more complex than
this is what I'm eating or this
is a good picture of my sushi,
you know?
And so, the utilitarian
nature and the publisher,
magazine kind of DNA is a very
important thing as you read this
chapter to understand.
Tumblr is actually Instagram,
they just fucked up.
Like they didn't
go mobile either.
So that was the big interesting
transition post Crush It!
even around The Thank You
Economy time if I wrote a book
it would've been interesting
because it would've
been more about mobile.
But I decided to go
more up here, right?
But Tumblr was the
one the really lost.
There are enormous amounts
of people on YouTube making
millions of dollars a year.
Enormous amounts,
like real long tail.
Millions, not just
hundreds of thousands in
creating video content.
Vlogging specifically is
interesting to me because I'm
very concerned that a lot of
you do not have actual talents.
That you're not funny.
That you're not super gorgeous.
That you're not athletic.
What's amazing
about vlogging is
it's the documenting
over creating.
It's the thing that so
many people make fun of the
Kardashians and all the
reality stars before them,
yet, those people have executed
on why you're reading this book.
They did it on a TV platform.
YouTube is the number
one network on the
mobile device for that behavior.
I believe that Facebook will
become a massive video player
even by the time this is
fully printed and distributed,
I'm aware and ready for Facebook
to be doing more stuff that
looks like YouTube, but YouTube
is a monster and if I have one
core recommendation, if you
just don't know what to do,
if you can't figure out if
you want to be the number one
authority about pajamas in
America, the number one move you
should do is to document your
day with your phone or fancy
camera and put it
up daily on YouTube
under the context of a vlog.
("The Journey"
by The Muse Maker)
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 248
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
What's your name, man?
- [Jonathan] I'm Jonathan.
- Alright, Jonathan.
- [Jonathan] LeClair
from Richland, Washington.
- I love it, man.
What's your question?
- [Jonathan] Okay, so you
started the 2017 Flip Challenge.
I decided to try
doing that selling books.
- Let me just say one thing,
let me say one thing Jonathan.
I apologize 'cause it just has
to be mentioned for everybody
who might not know this.
The reason the 2017 Flip
Challenge happened was because
I was on The Breakfast Club,
we were doing our thing.
Envy said, "Okay, give a
practical piece of advice."
Because I'm good and
I didn't fold and feel sad,
I came up with one on the spot
which was go buy stuff at the
dollar store and thrift stores,
sell stuff in your house and now
there are tens of thousands
of people selling stuff.
I'm getting crazy emails
of like I had no money,
now I have $4,000 'cause I sold
all my old clothes that I don't
wear so it's been huge.
I'm glad you jumped on it.
And thank you Charlamagne for
having me on the show to create
that little micro movement.
Go ahead, Jonathan.
- [Jonathan] Okay, so made
progress on that but it's going
slower than I'd like and
I'm only at a
couple thousand dollars.
- Only made a
- I want to punch
him in the face.
- Oh my God!
- Punch him.
- Only made a couple
thousand, come on, bro.
How much did you have before?
- Zero!
- See that's the problem with
a lot of these kids nowadays.
They want it now, instead of
realizing that you just got to
appreciate the process.
- And I'll say
something about Jonathan.
I can tell that him and his
homie wanted to be smarter.
They said, "Wait
a minute." Right?
Like, I can feel it from him.
Jonathan, here's
what I'm gonna say,
if you want to be the
platform that's such a big game.
Everybody wants to
be Uber and Airbnb and
Amazon and Google, right?
- [Jonathan] I don't
want to be the platform.
I want to still use
Amazon for reselling.
I just want to get the donation
so I don't have to pay over--
- I know that. You
want to be a platform.
You want to be a collection
platform for the inventory so
you can flip it.
The problem is you
have zero awareness.
- [Jonathan] Okay.
- You got to be annoying.
Now you got to be
DJ Khaled levels of annoying.
- You've got to be Charlamagne
is a fucking asshole but
he's my favorite one.
- Absolutely.
You got to be a lovable asshole.
There's nothing wrong
with selling yourself.
- Jonathan, before you worry
about scale I'm worried that you
didn't put enough...
One thing that people don't
realize is there's a lot of
different ways to flip.
Meaning you went to book.
That homie Rezy Resells
made a lot of money 'cause
he just went all macro.
He just bought every book.
And then just made the
arb and then decided what
to do with the bulk books.
Every single person watching
this right now can go to
Marshalls buy sneakers, flip
them on Amazon and make money.
Every single one.
Now, some people are happy with
$2,000 for 11 hours
of work this week.
Others aren't.
You've got to figure out if
reselling fits your ambition or
if you need to be doing
something altogether different.
What reselling is really good
for, in my opinion, is for people
that want to make under
$100,000 a year with the
19 hours a week that they waste.
That's set.
If you get really good--
- [Jonathan] Okay.
- and you're lucky.
I was giving that
advice 'cause Envy was
push me like I got nothing.
So I was doing that,
I said dollar store,
I was like six bucks.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Buy six tchotchkes,
make 11 back.
Go back buy 11,
11 tchotchkes, 19 back.
Go buy 19 tchotchkes, $43 back.
When I hear two
kids got 2,000 to start,
that's a $10,000
sneaker flip from Marshalls.
- I wonder what he wants.
Like what would be a number
that's a good goal for you?
What do you want?
What would make you happy?
- [Jonathan] Well,
what time scale?
- Yeah, but
okay, let's go there.
What's your time worth, bro?
What's your time
worth per hour, Jonathan?
- [Jonathan] This last week?
- No, no.
You've got this thought in your
mind of my time is so fucking
valuable that I've
got to make it efficient.
In your mind what is the
money you want to make per hour?
- [Jonathan] Well, I don't
have a time per hour,
I just have a goal for
about 15 years from now.
- What's the goal
15 years from now?
- [Jonathan] Couple
hundred million.
- Couple hundred million.
- Good, man.
- Okay.
- Call me.
- [Jonathan] Not that I
have a specific number like
$440 but that's 'cause
my ultimate ambition
is to go to Mars. (laughs)
- To go to Mars?
- [Jonathan] Yeah.
- Well, then, dude.
So you're telling me your
ultimate ambition is to go to
Mars not the
$440 million, right?
- [Jonathan] But I want
money to be able to pay--
- Got it.
- [Jonathan] three
times as much needed.
- So you're
hustling to go to Mars.
The way Gary
hustles to buy the Jets,
he's hustlin' to go to Mars.
- I like his better.
No, I'm super happy.
Jonathan, I think you should
literally document your journey
to Mars, bro. I'll watch it.
(Cha laughs)
Alright man, good luck.
Let's move on.
I mean listen,
I think, listen--
- That's an interrupt.
I've never heard that before.
He's selling books 'cause
he wants to leave the world.
(group laughter)
Wow.
- Let's get one more.
("The Journey"
by The Muse Maker)